salut c'est Romain demi l'idée de
culture générale j'ai deux petites
choses importantes à vous dire avant que
la vidéo ne commence première chose ne
regardez pas la vidéo comme ça avec du
pop-corn
[Musique]
si vous voulez retenir ce que vous allez
apprendre dans cette vidéo vous devez
prendre des notes les études sur la
mémorisation ne laissent aucune place au
doute ne pas prendre de notes égales
oublier donc faites-moi plaisir ouvrez
une application comme Google Docs web et
notez ce qui est essentiel pour vous au
fur et à mesure seconde chose que je
dois vous dire la vidéo que vous allez
regarder est extraite de ma formation de
culture générale qui s'appelle culture
Express c'est une formation qui permet
d'acquérir rapidement une bonne culture
générale sans se prendre la tête sans
avoir à lire ni à réfléchir elle couvre
tous les domaines de la culture générale
elle permet de maîtriser les
connaissances essentielles sur
l'histoire de l'humanité sur l'histoire
de France en économie en sciences
politiques en psychologie en sciences en
littérature en art en religion et enfin
en philosophie ah oui c'est important la
philo si ça vous intéresse je t'ai dit
un coup d’œil soit en cliquant sur le
lien qui apparaît maintenant en haut à
droite de la vidéo soit en cliquant sur
celui qui est dans la description de
cette vidéo voilà voilà je vous ai dit
ce que je voulais vous dire maintenant
je vous laisse regarder la vidéo
concentrez-vous préparez-vous à prendre
des notes et puis n'hésitez pas à
m'écrire dans les commentaires et moi je
vous dis à la prochaine
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que la science
la science fait partie de la culture
écrit pierre Thuillier dans les savoirs
ventriloques je me souviens de la
réaction de ma grand-mère lorsque il y a
une dizaine d'années je lui ai dit que
j'allais étudier la philosophie à la
Sorbonne en parallèle de mascularité en
école de commerce mais romain ce n'est
pas pour toi tu es un matheux sa
réaction illustre un préjugé bien ancré
dans la société française les sciences
et les lettres sont deux mondes
distincts hermétiques et peut-être même
antinomique dès l'école les enfants
doivent choisir entre scientifiques et
littéraires la société tout entière est
sommée de choisir cette distinction
repose fondamentalement sur l'idée que
la science est un discours sans appel
une forme supérieure de connaissance
dont la teneur en vérité la place
au-dessus des critiques et au dessus de
la culture comme autrefois la religion
impressionnée par les prouesses
techniques anesthésiées par le confort
l'homme moderne adhère à l'idée selon
laquelle la science est intouchable or
les travaux des historiens montrent que
la science à partir malgré tout à la
culture elle n'est pas le pur discours
de la vérité car elle s'inscrit dans une
réalité à la fois économique politique
et sociale après il faut reconnaître que
la science moderne produit des
connaissances d'un niveau de fiabilité
inédit mais on peut regretter le divorce
entre la science et la culture qui
grandit depuis les lumières les savants
des 16e et 17e siècle voyait eux le
savoir comme un seul et vaste ensemble
dont l'homme cultivé doit pouvoir
maîtriser la totalité
dans cette leçon je vais répondre aux
questions suivantes comment définir la
science quels sont les jalons de la
conception de la science comment la
science progresse-t-elle comment
classifier les sciences qui sont les
scientifiques les plus importants au 21e
siècle
comment définir la science je vais tout
d'abord vous expliquer comment parvenir
à une définition du mot science dans son
sens moderne je vous présenterai ensuite
les principaux usages de ce mot au
singulier et au pluriel enfin
j'évoquerai sans aller dans le détail
les méthodes de la science ainsi que
leur importance dans la définition de la
science
que signifie le mot science le nom
commun science vient du verbe latin
aspiré scire qui signifie savoir or
savoir c'est avoir une information
présente à l'esprit en être instruit par
exemple je sais que la température
extérieure est de moins 5 degrés je n'y
pense pas sans permanence mais cette
information se situe dans l'espace
mental de ma conscience elle est
accessible comme le dictionnaire posé à
ma droite sur mon bureau est accessible
en un petit mouvement de l'esprit je me
rappelle l'information comme en un petit
mouvement du corps je saisis le
dictionnaire
l'étymologie du mot science le lit donc
à l'idée de la possession de
l'information
mais l'idée de la science recèle une
autre dimension essentielle puis-je dire
que je sais que la température
extérieure est de 25 degrés quand elle
est en réalité de moins 5 degrés non
cela n'a pas de sens cette information
fausse la température extérieure est de
25 degrés cette information est absente
de mon esprit comme toutes les autres
informations fausses par exemple la
température extérieure est de 52 degrés
parce que ces informations sont
inutiles sinon nocives du point de vue
de la vie en revanche savoir que la
température extérieure est de moins 5
degrés est utile je vais par exemple me
munir de mon bonnet de mon écharpe et de
mes gants pour sortir mon chien ainsi
l'idée de sciences implique que
l'information que je possède soit vrai
mais comment définir la vérité les
philosophes ont énormément réfléchi et
écrit pour répondre à cette question
donc je vais me contenter d'une réponse
simple et satisfaisante la vérité et la
correspondance entre la pensée et la
réalité
si je pense à une chose et que cette
chose existe alors elle est vraie par
exemple je pense que la température
extérieure est de -5° et cet
effectivement le cas donc l'information
est vrai mais si j'imagine que j'ai
terminé d'écrire le script de cette
leçon la réalité n'est pas conforme à
cette pensée à l'instant où j'écris ces
lignes donc ce n'est pas vrai c'est un
fantasme mais il deviendra la vérité
dans une dizaine d'heures la définition
de la science par la vérité pose
cependant un problème comment être
certain que l'information que je possède
est bien vrai il y a diverses manières
d'atteindre cette certitude ou plutôt de
s'en rapprocher mais la certitude
absolue est un idéal par exemple suis-je
absolument certains que la température
extérieure est de moins 5 degrés et si
le thermomètre est cassé ce n'est pas
impossible du tout alors pourquoi
considérer cette information comme vrai
parce que je pense que le thermomètre
fonctionne à ma connaissance il ne s'est
jamais trompé depuis que je l'utilise
donc je fais le pari qu'il ne se trompe
pas aujourd'hui
soit le résultat de l'effort de
production c'est-à-dire l'ensemble des
connaissances fiables produites c'est
dans ce sens qu'on dit faire étalage de
sa science
mais la science peut être aussi
l'organisation des connaissances fiables
produites c'est dans ce sens qu'on dit
par exemple que la chimie est une
science
la science est du savoir organiser écrit
Herbert Spencer dans éducation si vous
voulez une définition plus simple vous
pouvez retenir que la science est une
forme de savoir particulier distinct du
savoir philosophique politique religieux
artistique etc et une forme de savoir
qui se caractérise par un niveau de
fiabilité supérieure
quels sont les principaux usages du mot
science ce mot a une longue histoire
c'est pourquoi il existe aujourd'hui
dans la langue française de nombreux
usages qui ne correspondent plus
forcément à la définition moderne voici
les principaux usages du mot science il
est utilisé au singulier pour signifier
une compétence une habileté spécifique
par exemple une personne qui a la
science du monde cette personne est à
l'aise et habile dans les mondanités
elle en connaît les codes et elle CER se
rendre agréable dans la vie sociale des
élites autre exemple on peut dire que la
science du cavalier consiste notamment
dans l'accord de la main et des jambes
la science-fiction est une expression
qui vient des États-Unis elle désigne un
sous genre de la fiction qui met à
profit des hypothèses et des résultats
de la science de l'époque voire une
anticipation des résultats futurs pour
inventer un monde qui frappe
l'imagination par exemple Matrix est un
film de science-fiction
les sciences de la nature ou science
naturelle sont les disciplines qui ont
pour objet le monde naturel c'est-à-dire
le monde physique indépendant de
l'action humaine par exemple la zoologie
qui étudie les animaux ou encore la
botanique qui étudie les végétaux sont
des sciences de la nature
les sciences morales sont les sciences
qui ont pour objet l'esprit humain et
les rapports sociaux cette expression
était surtout utilisée au 19e siècle
dans le but de rassembler toutes les
sciences entre guillemets non physiques
c'est-à-dire qui ne porte pas sur la
matière par exemple la philosophie la
psychologie le droit ou l'histoire sont
des sciences morales mais l'expression
est tombée en désuétude au 20e siècle
les sciences humaines et l'expression
qu'il a remplacé elle met davantage
l'accent sur le fait que les disciplines
étudie les comportements individuels et
collectifs directement observables des
hommes attention une science relative à
l'homme n'est pas forcément une science
humaine par exemple l'anatomie n'est pas
une science humaine ainsi une science
humaine étudie ce qui caractérise
l'homme par rapport au reste de la
nature
les sciences appliquées sont les
sciences qui ont pour objet comme leur
nom l'indique d'appliquer à une fin
pratique des connaissances théoriques on
parle par exemple de la physique
appliquée ou des mathématiques
appliquées Louis Pasteur a critiqué
cette expression parce qu'elle suggère
que l'application des connaissances
scientifiques est une activité de
technologie et non plus de science enfin
les sciences occultes sont les
disciplines et qui produisent des
connaissances dont la transmission est
orale il n'y a pas d'archives et
ésotérique c'est-à-dire réservé à une
minorité d'initié la magie l'astrologie
ou la diminution sont des sciences de
culte la plupart s'évanouissent quand on
les soumet à la critique mais il y a des
exceptions comme l'hypnose
quelles sont les méthodes de la science
la science se définit fondamentalement
par l'exercice d'une méthode car la
méthode est le moyen de garantir la
fiabilité des connaissances produites
issues du grec méthodos qui signifie
cheminement recherche une méthode
consiste précisément en une suite
d'opérations à accomplir pour arriver à
un résultat en évitant des errements
le discours de la méthode de Descartes
et le livre emblématique de la
définition de la science par la méthode
pour illustrer l'importance de la
méthode Descartes reprend la métaphore
du chemin de Sénèque dans la vie
heureuse réfléchir sans méthode c'est
comme se précipiter en changeant sans
cesse de direction on ne risque pas
d'arriver quelque part rien ne sert donc
d'aller vite si on n'est pas sur le bon
chemin des cartes prétendent avoir
trouvé je cite la vraie méthode pour
parvenir à la connaissance de toutes les
choses dont mon esprit serait capable il
écrit cela dans son Discours de la
méthode
Descartes à élaborer cette méthode
spéciale dont je vous parlerai dans la
quatrième leçon en s'inspirant du
raisonnement mathématique les
mathématiques étant à ses yeux la
science la plus fiable et il s'engage à
en faire bon usage pour progresser dans
la vérité
ce que montre le propos de Descartes
c'est que la science se caractérise tout
d'abord par une méthode de raisonnement
en effet la science demande de réfléchir
en suivant des règles qui permettent de
passer d'une proposition à une autre en
étant certains que si la proposition de
départ est vraie alors la proposition
d'arriver est aussi par exemple j'ai le
droit de passer de Michael Jordan mesure
un mètre 98 à Michael Jordan mesure
moins de 2 mètres en revanche je n'ai
pas le droit de faire l'inverse de
passer de Michael Jordan mesure moins de
2 mètres à Michael Jordan mesure un
mètre 98 parce que le fait que quelqu'un
mesure moins de 2 mètres ne signifie pas
forcément qu'il mesure un mètre 98 il
pourrait mesurer un mètre 80 par exemple
les règles qui permettent de faire
circuler la vérité d'une proposition à
la suivante relève de la logique la
logique est au sens strict la science de
la validité des opérations
intellectuelles pour trouver la vérité
la science se caractérise encore par les
méthodes qui permettent de faire
circuler la vérité entre les niveaux
général et particuliers une vérité
générale est décrite un ensemble
d'éléments ou bien pose une
caractéristique commune aux éléments
d'un ensemble par exemple les joueurs de
l'équipe mesure plus d'un mètre 90 est
une vérité générale en revanche Michael
Jordan mesure 1m98 est une vérité
particulière parce qu'elle concerne un
élément en l'occurrence un individu
unique
pour comprendre la transmission de la
vérité entre les général et le
particulier il faut s'intéresser à
l'opposition classique entre la
déduction et l'induction
la déduction du latin déductiaux actions
d'emmener et l'opération logique par
laquelle on passe d'une proposition
générale à une proposition précise qui
en est la conséquence nécessaire par
exemple je connais la loi de la
gravitation universelle théorisée par
Newton au XVIIe siècle et Jean déduit
que la pomme qui est tombée de l'arbre
sur ma tête a été attiré par la terre la
méthode de déductive permet par exemple
de faire des découvertes dans le monde
physique à partir de vérités générales
de nature mathématique
l'induction du latin induction action
d'amener et l'opération mentale qui
consiste à remonter de propositions
particulières à des propositions plus
générales par exemple je sais qu'à
chaque fois que je tiens un livre dans
ma main puis que j'ouvre ma main le
livre tombe j'induit de ses cas
particuliers qu'une force attire
naturellement le livre vers le sol le
philosophe Carl Popper prétend néanmoins
que l'induction n'est pas une méthode
100% fiable parce qu'il y a toujours le
risque que des cas particuliers inconnus
Invalides la vérité générale par exemple
je regarde la taille de la grande
majorité des joueurs de basket de la NBA
et Jean induit qu'un joueur de ce
championnat mesure toujours plus d'un
mètre 90 or il est possible que je n'ai
pas remarqué la minorité de joueurs de
moins d'un mètre 90 auquel cas la
méthode de l'induction va entraîner à
poser une proposition générale fausse le
scientifique recourt à la méthode
inductive lorsqu'il observe et où
lorsqu'ils mène des expériences puis
théorise des lois à partir des résultats
de ces expériences
l'opposition entre la déduction et
l'induction est à l'origine de deux
méthodes scientifiques tout d'abord la
méthode hypothétique qui consiste à
formuler une hypothèse générale puis à
en examiner la validité en étudiant les
vérités particulières qui doivent
découler de l'hypothèse générale
et puis la méthode empirique qui
consiste à partir de vérités
particuliers des faits des données
observables pour remonter vers une
hypothèse générale susceptible de les
expliquer
quels sont les jalons de la conception
de la science je vais tout d'abord vous
parler des conceptions de la science qui
prévalent dans l’antiquité j'évoquerai
dans un deuxième temps la conception de
la science qui émerge à l'époque moderne
à partir du 17e siècle je vous
expliquerai ensuite la conception de la
science qui s'impose au 19e siècle le
positivisme enfin je vous présenterai
les conceptions de la science les plus
influentes à l'heure actuelle
qu'est-ce que la science dans
l'Antiquité dans l’antiquité la science
n'est pas un domaine séparé de
l'intelligence humaine elle est plus
particulièrement soumise à la
philosophie qui chapote et oriente toute
quête de la vérité les scientifiques
entre guillemets de l'antiquité sont
tous également des philosophes
les conceptions essentielles sont celles
des deux géants de la pensée antique
Platon tout d'abord emploie le terme
science dans plusieurs sens mais dans sa
classification des degrés de la
connaissance il affirme que la science
et le degré le plus élevé sa conception
de la science est liée à sa théorie des
Idées la véritable science se
caractérise par son objet les idées
c'est-à-dire les modèles et essences
éternels de la réalité dans la
République il rapproche cette science
des mathématiques comme les maths de
monde de manipuler des objets purement
abstraits elles entraînent l'âme à
s'élever vers la vérité enfin Platon
définit aussi la science par une méthode
intellectuelle spéciale la seule qui
permet d’atteindre l'essence des choses
la dialectique elle consiste
essentiellement en pratique à raisonner
en reprenant les règles d'une discussion
rigoureuse dont notamment la définition
des termes et le classement des idées
aristote a une vision de la science plus
proche de la nôtre il admet une
diversité de sciences qui ne sont pas
toutes parfaite il répète même qu'il ne
faut pas exiger de toutes les
disciplines intellectuelles le même
degré d'exactitude
il ne faut pas plus exiger une précision
égale dans toutes les œuvres de l'esprit
qu'on ne l'exige pour les ouvrages de la
main écrit Aristote dans son éthique à
Nicolas
dans le détail il subdivise la science
en trois grands domaines la science
théorique les mathématiques par exemple
la science pratique qui est tournée vers
l'action la science politique par
exemple et la science productive qui
comme son nom l'indique sert à produire
quelque chose l'agriculture par exemple
sa conception de la science est bien
moins abstraite que celle de Platon
Aristote c'est lui-même confronté au
monde matériel pour le comprendre je
vous explique dans la leçon suivante
consacrée aux origines de la science
pourquoi et comment la conception de la
science d'Aristote plutôt que celle de
son maître a été décisive dans le
développement de la tradition
scientifique occidentale
qu'est-ce que la science moderne deux
philosophes et scientifiques
emblématiques de l’époque moderne on
façonné la conception de la science
moderne l'anglais Francis Bacon est le
promoteur de référence de l'empirisme du
grec mpia empe Iria qui signifie
expérience il promet l'empirisme
c'est-à-dire la nécessité de fonder et
de développer la science à partir de
l'observation de la réalité de
l'expérience sensible il défend cette
thèse dans le novembre
ensuite le français René Descartes que
j'ai déjà évoqué à propos de
l'importance de la méthode René
Descartes et le promoteur de référence
du raisonnement scientifique le progrès
de la connaissance demande que l'homme
discipline sa pensée qu'il la straignent
à une démarche rigoureuse comparable à
celle du raisonnement mathématique des
cartes défenses et test dans son fameux
discours de la méthode je vous explique
en détail ces deux visions de la science
dans la quatrième leçon du module
consacrée à la naissance de la science
moderne
qu'est-ce que le positivisme le mot
positivisme vient du latin positivus qui
signifie qui repose sur quelque chose
établi conventionnel cet étymologie met
en évidence c'est l'idée d'une base
solide dont la fiabilité produise
l'accord des esprits or dans la
conception positiviste de la science la
fiabilité de la connaissance repose sur
le fait mais qu'est-ce qu'un fait
issu du latin face serré faire le mot
fait définit une chose qui existe ou qui
survient et dont la réalité est
incontestable elle est évidente ou
admise ainsi le positivisme pose que la
science équivaut à la connaissance des
faits c'est de cette idée que découle
une dimension fondamentale de la science
moderne l'exigence de la mesure en
mesurant rigoureusement ce qu'il observe
le scientifique alimente le progrès de
la connaissance en fait objectif cette
démarche signifie plus fondamentalement
que la science n'a pas pour mission
comme le prétentelon de découvrir
l'essence même de la réalité
que ce borner à identifier des lois
c'est à dire des relations invariables
de succession et de similitudes entre
les phénomènes
cette conception de la science s'impose
au 19e et 20e siècle son fondateur et le
philosophe français du 19e siècle
Auguste Comte il présente la conception
positiviste de la science dans son cours
de philosophie positive
tous les bons esprits répètent depuis
bacon qu'il n'y a de connaissance réelle
que celle qui repose sur des faits
observées écrit Auguste Comte dans son
cours de philosophie positive
plus qu'une nouvelle thèse le
positivisme apparaît comme une idéologie
il exprime en effet une confiance dans
le progrès scientifique et qui aboutit à
remplacer Dieu par l'humanité armée de
la science désormais la science suffit à
guider les actions des hommes cette
radicalisation du positivisme donne ce
qu'on appelle le scientisme l'attitude
qui consiste à croire que seule la
science et source de vérité et qu'elle a
la capacité de satisfaire tous les
besoins de l'intelligence humaine bref
la science devient une religion
à quelle conception la science du 21e
siècle obéit-elle les deux principaux
artisans de la formulation des règles
qui gouvernent le développement de la
science sont Claude Bernard un médecin
français du 19e siècle et Carl Popper un
philosophe autrichien du 20e siècle
voici leur conception de la science
Claude Bernard et le penseur de
référence de la méthode expérimentale il
s'agit d'une démarche qui repose sur le
contrôle d'une hypothèse de départ au
moyen d'expérience répétée d'où
l'adjectif expérimental et les
expériences répétées permettent
d'étudier l'influence des paramètres
dans le détail Claude Bernard distingue
deux postures l'observateur se contente
de constater les phénomènes
l'expérimentateur lui résonne à partir
des données qu'il a obtenu afin de
provoquer de nouveaux phénomènes cette
distinction explique que l'approche
expérimentale ne se réduit pas à une
simple approche empirique il s'agit plus
précisément d'une méthode hypothétique
au déductive que Claude Bernard
décompose en trois temps la naissance
d'un sentiment à partir de l'observation
stérile sans hypothèse de départ de la
nature l'application de la raison pour
produire une hypothèse rationnelle et la
vérification de l'hypothèse par
l'expérience cette méthode élaborée pour
empêcher le dogmatisme et celle de la
recherche médicale moderne
il faut modifier une théorie pour
l'adapter à la nature et non la nature
pour l'adapter à la théorie écrit Claude
Bernard dans son Introduction à l'étude
de la médecine expérimentale
Carl Popper fond de la science sur la
falsification qui signifie que le
scientifique doit chercher à prouver que
son hypothèse est fausse plutôt que
selon la tendance naturelle de l'esprit
humain de chercher à prouver qu'il a
raison cette exigence découle du fait
que la vérité n'existe que sur un mode
négatif et temporaire une chose est
vraie tant qu'on n'a pas montré qu'elle
est fausse le chercheur ne peut donc
avoir de certitudes que sur ce qui est
faux cette conception de la vérité fonde
une méthode scientifique posée une
hypothèse puis la mettre à l'épreuve par
des tests reproductibles de plus en plus
précis afin de corriger l'hypothèse de
départ par essai et erreurs ainsi pour
poper une théorie véritablement
scientifique ne peut pas être vérifiée
elle doit toujours être réfutable ou
falsifiable il en conclut que les
disciplines qui se prémunissent contre
la réfutation ne sont pas de véritables
sciences c'est par exemple le cas de la
psychanalyse
lire réfutabilité n'est pas vertu mais
défaut écrit Carl Popper dans conjecture
et réfutations
comment la science progresse-t-elle je
vais vous présenter les trois tests de
référence sur le progrès de la
connaissance scientifique celle selon
laquelle à la science avance par une
sorte de sélection naturelle celle selon
laquelle elle avance par révolution
successives et enfin celle selon
laquelle elle évolue en réalité de
manière anarchique
y a-t-il une sélection naturelle entre
guillemets des idées scientifiques en
fondant la science sur la falsification
car le Popper développe une conception
du progrès de la connaissance qu'on peut
qualifier d'évolutionnistes en référence
à la théorie de l'évolution de Darwin de
son point de vue le processus
d'accroissement des connaissances dans
l'espèce humaine et comparable à
l'émergence et au développement des
espèces vivantes à travers l’évolution
biologique parmi les hypothèses et
théories proposées par les scientifiques
certaines survivront aux autres parce
qu'elles sont plus résistantes aux
tentatives de réfutation
les progrès du savoir sont
essentiellement la transformation d'un
savoir antérieur écrit car le Popper
dans des sources de la connaissance et
de l'ignorance
seulement comme pour une espèce animale
la résistance d'une théorie scientifique
ne garantit pas sa pérennité elle peut
résister à la réfutation pendant
longtemps puis finalement céder un jour
par exemple le géocentrisme la théorie
selon laquelle la terre est au centre de
l'univers le géocentrisme après dominé
dans l'astronomie occidentale de
l’antiquité jusqu'au 16ème siècle au
cours duquel les contestations en ont
finalement eu raison le géocentrisme a
perdu son crédit scientifique et a été
remplacé par l'héliocentrisme la théorie
selon laquelle c'est le soleil qui est
au centre de l'univers ainsi pour Popper
une théorie scientifique est un discours
organisé à propos d'une partie de la
réalité et qui demeure ouvert à la
confirmation ou à la mise en question
dans cette perspective la connaissance
scientifique évolue dans un univers
distinct de celui des hommes de la
communauté scientifique qui la font et
qu'il examine Popper distingue plus
précisément trois univers l'univers
physique l’univers de l'expérience
psychologique subjective ce qui se passe
dans l'esprit humain enfin l'univers des
produits de la création humaine qui
comprend la connaissance scientifique
la science se progresse-t-elle par
révolution taux masculin affirme que la
science progresse grâce à des
révolutions ponctuelles dans la
structure des révolutions scientifiques
qui est le livre de référence du 20e
siècle en histoire des sciences il
affirme que les progrès de la science ne
se résument pas à une accumulation
continue et linéaire de connaissances
mais qu'il se concrétise au contraire
par des phénomènes sociaux majeurs ou
une nouvelle vision du monde en remplace
une autre considérée comme obsolète du
fait de son unification scientifique
dans son activité normale entre
guillemets la science se caractérise par
une unité de pensée relativement stable
autour d'un cadre théorique consensuel
c'est ce que qu'une appelle un paradigme
un ensemble de modèles acceptés comme
cadre de travail commun par les
scientifiques un paradigme scientifique
se définit plus précisément par quatre
éléments principaux des principes
métaphysiques généraux qui orientent la
vision du monde des scientifiques des
hypothèses et des lois une méthodologie
qui délimite les comportements conformes
et enfin les outils permettant
l'observation scientifique une fois un
paradigme installé l'activité
scientifique se résume essentiellement à
l'améliorer c'est à des opérations de
nettoyage que se consacre la plupart des
scientifiques durant toute leur carrière
et crypto masculin dans la structure des
révolutions scientifiques mais au bout
d'un moment les ajustements du paradigme
ne suffisent plus pour résoudre les
problèmes posés les échecs à moins de
risques la confiance de la communauté
scientifique dans le paradigme et font
émerger des efforts scientifiques plus
spéculatif et éloigné du paradigme par
exemple les échecs répétés de la théorie
de Ptolémée dans la détermination de la
position des planètes et des étoiles ont
entraîné l'émergence de la théorie
copernicienne qui réussit elle en
comparaison avec une précision inégalée
si la contestation du paradigme me
suscite une résistance des scientifiques
en même temps elle renouvelle leur
vision du monde et leurs outils
la révolution scientifique introduit un
nouveau paradigme elle n'est pas une
rupture brutale et immédiate mais un
processus progressif et graduel elle
avance par les prises de position
successives des scientifiques confrontés
à la crise de leur paradigme elle n'est
véritablement achevée que lorsque la
communauté scientifique se rallie à une
nouvelle théorie consensuelle qui permet
de dépasser le paradigme antérieur par
exemple le passage au 20e siècle de la
physique de Newton à la physique
d'Einstein est un véritable changement
de vision du monde car l'espace et le
temps non plus le même sens
le progrès de la science est-il
anarchique un penseur a radicalement
remis en cause la vision traditionnelle
de la science à la fin des trentes
glorieuses dans contre la méthode
paulfire habed affirme que la science
est loin d'être le discours de rigueur
d'objectivité et de méthode qu'elle
prétent être à ses yeux les
épistémologues c'est-à-dire ceux qui
étudient les principes et les méthodes
de la science à ses yeux les
épistémologues et les historiens de la
science plaquent leur croyance leur
dogmatisme même lorsqu'ils décrivent
l'évolution de la connaissance
scientifique
reprenons l'histoire de la science fire
à Bund estime qu'elle évolue
essentiellement par des coups de force
cette théorie s'appelle l'anarchisme
épistémologique l'anarchie et le
désordre sont donc les véritables
facteurs du progression scientifique
dans les faits les savants ne
réussissent bien souvent à produire du
nouveau quand s’émancipant des règles
trop étroites de la recherche le
véritable génie scientifique et celui
qui
ose bousculer les certitudes et les
préjugés il se sert de toutes les
ressources à sa disposition il n'hésite
pas à tricher ou à aller chercher son
inspiration dans les domaines les plus
surprenants bref l'image traditionnelle
de la démarche scientifique serait une
illusion
la science est beaucoup plus proche du
mythe qu'une philosophie scientifique
n’est prête à l'admettre écrit Paul
fayerham dedans contre la méthode
en définitive la science ne serait que
l'une des nombreuses formes de pensée
qui ont été développées par l'homme et
même pas forcément la meilleure les
scientifiques qui la considèrent comme
une forme supérieure de connaissance
sont des idéologues qui n'ont pas
réfléchi aux limites de leur mode de
pensée firebend plaid pour un
développement libertaire du savoir hors
de tout carcan méthodologique
comment classifier les sciences je vais
tout d'abord vous expliquer la
différence entre d'une part à les
sciences dites exactes ou dures même si
cet adjectif est un anglicisme
controversé parce qu'il dévalorise les
autres disciplines comme des sciences
molles et d'autre part les sciences
dites Humaines je vous présenterai
ensuite les sciences exactes puis les
sciences humaines les plus importantes
dans la culture occidentale
quelle est la différence entre les
sciences exactes et les sciences
humaines la distinction entre les
humaines et récentes dans l'histoire de
la science occidentale elle date du 19e
siècle comme je vous l'ai déjà dit la
science au sens où nous l'entendons
aujourd'hui était autrefois intégré dans
l'ensemble du savoir pendant longtemps
le physicien est un philosophe de la
nature le scientifique était un savant
qui s'intéresse à diverses formes de
connaissances il est souvent un polymate
ainsi le mathématicien Pythagore fait de
la philosophie théorie et la politique
l'éducation et créer une secte
Hippocrate le père de la médecine
occidentale est aussi philosophe
Aristote qui passe pour le fondateur de
la biologie veut tout savoir surtout
Léonard de Vinci qui incarne la figure
du polymate de la Renaissance montre que
le scientifique peut également être un
artiste Einstein dira que le
scientifique doit être un artiste enfin
l'encyclopédiste des lumières dont
Diderot est peut-être le meilleur
exemple et la dernière figure du savant
universel occidental
mais le progrès de la science impose une
nouvelle organisation du savoir d'un
côté les sciences exactes qui
comprennent dans un même ensemble les
sciences de la nature et les sciences
formelles de l'autre côté les sciences
humaines qui étudient les comportements
individuels ou collectifs directement
observables des hommes
la thèse de référence qui explique cette
séparation et celle de villalmiltait il
affirme que les sciences humaines ne
forment un champ spécifique du savoir
parce que leur objet ne se résume pas à
la nature mais qu’il inclut également la
subjectivité humaine c'est-à-dire la
manière dont l'homme donne un sens à son
existence c'est la raison pour laquelle
il les appelle science de l'esprit il en
déduit que ces sciences ne peuvent pas
travailler avec les mêmes méthodes que
les sciences de la nature et que les
positivistes font donc fausse route dans
sa perspective la méthode des sciences
naturelles repose sur l'explication au
sens où elle les identifient
l'enchaînement objectif de cause qui
produit un phénomène naturel la méthode
des sciences humaines quant à elle
repose sur la compréhension au sens où
elle synthétise des actes ou des paroles
sous un sens général
une chute d'eau se compose de molécules
homogènes juxtaposées mais une simple
phrase qui n'est pourtant qu'un souffle
sorti de notre bouche peut ébranler
toute l'âme d'une société et tout un
continent
écrivithiltait dans son Introduction à
l'étude des sciences humaines
quelles sont les principales sciences
exactes je vais vous les présenter en
fonction de leur importance dans
l'histoire de la science occidentale je
vais distinguer d'une part les sciences
dites formelles qui étudient les objets
intellectuels ainsi que leur relation et
d'autre part les sciences de la nature
qui étudient le monde physique
indépendant de l'action humaine il
existe bien sûr des liens entre ces deux
types de sciences par exemple les
mathématiques sont aujourd'hui
indispensables en physique voici les
principales sciences formelles les
mathématiques sont la science qui
consiste à mener des raisonnements sur
des objets abstraits comme les nombres
les figures ou encore les structures
c'est l'idéal de la science exacte
depuis le 20e siècle les autres sciences
exactes et même les sciences humaines se
mettent à traiter mathématiquement leur
donner pour renforcer leur crédibilité
scientifique
la logique et la science de la validité
des opérations intellectuelles elle
faisait partie de la philosophie depuis
l’antiquité Aristote passe pour le
fondateur de la logique dans la pensée
occidentale mais les mathématiques y ont
été introduites comme dans d'autres
disciplines au 20e siècle
l'informatique et la science du
traitement rationnel et automatique de
l'information l'ordinateur en est une
application le traitement repose sur
l'algorithme qui est une suite finie et
non ambiguë d'opération permettant
d'atteindre un résultat
voici maintenant les principales
sciences de la nature l'astronomie du
grec Astron astre et nomos loi
l'astronomie et la science qui étudie
les corps célestes dans leur position
leur mouvement et leur constitution
c'est une des sciences les plus
anciennes la médecine du latin médéor et
la science qui étudie les moyens de
prévenir même si cette dimension est
négligée et de traiter les maladies ma
mère me répétait que la médecine n'est
pas une science exacte pour me dire que
le niveau de fiabilité du savoir médical
n'est pas le même que celui des sciences
emblématiques des sciences exactes comme
les mathématiques ou la physique
enfin l'anthropologie du grec anthropos
qui signifie humain et logos qui
signifie discours l'anthropologie et la
science qui étudie les caractéristiques
des populations humaines je la range
parmi les sciences exactes parce qu'elle
produit des connaissances fiables sur
l'histoire de l'humanité mais elle est
aussi une science humaine
quelles sont les principales sciences
humaines l'expression sciences humaines
est propre à la langue française on dit
plutôt au Sochaux signes ou humanitise
en anglais le système éducatif français
dit aussi sciences humaines et sociales
SHS je ne vais pas évoquer l'évolution
de la catégorie car c'est un débat
académique qui n'a pas d'intérêt pour
mieux comprendre le monde les sciences
humaines actuellement les plus
importantes dans la culture occidentale
sont l'économie l'histoire la
psychologie la sociologie et la
philosophie formée à partir du latin
sociaux qui signifie uni mis en commun
et Durc logos qui signifie discours la
sociologie étudie les phénomènes sociaux
à partir de leurs propriétés propres
pour les définitions des autres sciences
humaines je vous renvoie au premier
leçon des modules correspondants on peut
encore mentionner le droit la science
politique et la géographie parmi les
sciences humaines qui comptent dans la
culture occidentale au 21e siècle
qui sont les scientifiques les plus
importants au 21e siècle je vais vous
présenter cinq scientifiques qui
comptent parmi les plus importants dans
la culture occidentale au début du 21e
siècle un physicien de biologiste une
anthropologue et un mathématicien j'ai
essayé d'estimer l'influence culturelle
des plus grands scientifiques de notre
époque mais il y a forcément une part de
subjectivité dans mon choix n'hésitez
donc pas à me suggérer d'autres noms
dans les commentaires
que retenir de Stephen Hawking Stephen
Hawking est un physicien et cosmologiste
britannique mort en 2018 considéré comme
un des plus brillants physiciens depuis
Einstein il est sans doute le
scientifique le plus célèbre au début du
21e siècle sur le plan scientifique il a
contribué à notre compréhension du Big
Bang l'explosion à l'origine de
l'univers qui se serait produite il y a
environ 14 milliards d'années et dont je
vous parle dans la dernière leçon du
module il a aussi contribué à notre
compréhension des trous noirs et de la
relativité il doit sa notoriété au
succès de ses livres de vulgarisation le
premier qu'il a publié en 1988 une brève
histoire du temps est immédiatement
devenue un best-seller il y retrace les
grandes théories de l'univers depuis
Galilée il essaie aussi de relever le
plus grand défi de la science moderne
rendre compatible la théorie de la
relativité qui explique l'infiniment
grand et la mécanique quantique qui
explique l'infiniment petit sur le plan
personnel Stephen Hawking est un homme
inspirant parce qu'il souffre depuis sa
vingtaine d'une maladie rare qui a
dégénéré jusqu'à le laisser presque
complètement paralysé il vivait donc
dans une chaise roulante équipée d'un
matériel informatique ce handicap est
raconté dans le film biographique une
merveilleuse histoire du temps
que retenir de Francis Creek et James
Watson franzis écrit et James Watson
forment un des couples de chercheurs les
plus célèbres de la science moderne pas
un couple au sens romantique ils ont
découvert la structure en double hélice
de l'ADN en 1953 ce qui leur a valu le
prix Nobel de médecine en 1962 Francis
cric est un biologiste britannique du
20e siècle il est décédé en 2004 pour
l'anecdote son nom est associé à la
théorie de la panse permis dirigée selon
laquelle l'origine de la vie sur Terre
serait dû à une contamination
extraterrestre délibérée son argument
est que l’adn de l'être humain qu'il
connaît bien semble être le résultat
d'une évolution bien plus longue que
l'histoire d'Homo sapiens sur la terre
l'ADN aurait donc commencé à évoluer
ailleurs James Watson quant à lui est un
biologiste moléculaire et généticien
américain il est toujours vivant à
l'heure où j'écris ce script en novembre
2022 il a suscité la controverse à la
fin des années 2000 en évoquant
l'existence d'un lien génétique entre
l'intelligence et la race
je vous raconte la découverte de la
structure de l'ADN dans la septième
leçon du module
que retenir de Jane goodle Jane Godal
est une anthropologue britannique
toujours vivante elle est célèbre parce
qu'elle est considérée comme la plus
grande experte au monde sur les
chimpanzés qui sont les animaux les plus
proches des êtres humains nous
partageons 98% de nos gènes avec eux sur
le plan scientifique elle a analysé les
interactions familiales et sociales des
chimpanzés avec des études de terrain
pendant plus de 50 ans son travail a été
révolutionnaire dans la mesure où il a
montré que les chimpanzés peuvent
apprendre à fabriquer et à utiliser des
outils alors qu'on croyait jusqu'à lors
que c'est une propriété humaine elle a
également remis en cause la vision
idyllique des chimpanzés liée à la
croyance selon laquelle la violence est
propre à l'organisation des sociétés
humaines elle a remis en cause cette
vision en mettant en évidence le fait
que les chimpanzés peuvent être très
violents par exemple certains adultes
chassent et mangent des singes plus
petits
sur le plan personnel elle met son nom
et son influence au service de la
protection de l'environnement elle a
notamment fondé l'Institut Jane goodle
pour la protection de la biodiversité
l'aide au développement durable et
l'éducation
que retenir d'Anjou wild
Anjou Wilds et moins connu que les trois
autres scientifiques que je viens de
vous présenter mais je l'ai choisi parce
qu'il est un des mathématiciens les plus
connus britanniques Profa Oxford il est
entré dans l'histoire de la science en
démontrant ce qu'on appelle le grand
théorème de Fermat en 1994 Pierre de
Fermat est un mathématicien français de
l’époque de Descartes c'est un
accomplissement exceptionnel parce que
cela faisait plus de 300 ans que
personne n'y était arrivé au point que
les mathématiciens considéraient la
démonstration comme impossible
wild lui il parvient de manière
originale il démontre que le grand
théorème de Fermat est une conséquence
d'un autre théorème en vertu de quoi il
lui suffit de démontrer l'autre théorème
en question la première dimension
intéressante de la découverte et que
wise travaille sur un univers
mathématique particulier les propriétés
des courbes pour prouver un théorème qui
concerne un autre univers mathématique
le grand théorème de Fermat concerne la
théorie des nombres la seconde dimension
intéressante et que Wild avant cependant
huit ans dans le plus grand secret ce
n'est pas une partie de plaisir mais
wild se sait qu'il n'est pas rare dans
l'histoire de la science que plusieurs
scientifiques prétendent de faire la
même découverte en même temps il
présente sa solution en 1993 c'est père
trouve quelques failles et wild vient à
bout de ses failles en un peu plus d'un
an
alors la vidéo vous a plu j'espère que
oui je vous rappelle que c'est un
extrait de ma formation culture générale
culture Express si vous voulez en savoir
plus cliquez sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de les
vidéos ou bien sur celui qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo voilà voilà
comme d'habitude n'hésitez pas à
m'écrire dans les commentaires et puis
surtout n'oubliez pas que vous n'avez
pas besoin de vous prendre la tête pour
vous cultiver